hi my name is Sylvia um today I'm going
to be talking about some of the work
that we have going on in my lab I'm not
going to be talking about all of it I do
want to quickly highlight uh my lab
which has grown very quickly since
starting uh at the end of 2020 I have
these wonderful PhD students and
undergraduate and master students and
they're working on a range of projects I
want to quickly mention things that I
won't be talking about today in case
anybody wants to meet up later so we do
a lot of work on this thing called
reachability Theory I'll go into it a
little bit more uh safe reinforcement
learning using iterative reachability
estimation is something that we've been
working on uh something called cman hop
reachability analysis for fast and
scalable nonlinear reachability
approximations where we can for example
drive this 10d glycolysis model the ATP
levels up to desired values uh very
efficiently
advances in reachability using system
decomposition and handling noise and
partial
observations uh we also have some work
that's just more generally control and
machine learning uh reasoning about
safety when interacting with uncertain
environments so for example debris AKA
Pringle scans that you need to move
around to get to a goal while hopefully
not knocking them over and you have to
reason about this
online uh continuously trading model
error with planning speed so how can you
get away with as much error as possible
such that you can still make your way
towards the
goal uh conformal prediction and
temporal correlations for reducing
conservativeness and pedestrian
preditions while maintaining safety and
some control theory applied to policy
gradient methods identifying when the
optimization landscape and the control
policy space is very non-s smooth or
fractal using control theory I know that
was very fast but I just want to give a
quick highlight on some of the other
directions that we're doing that I'm not
going into
today today I'm mostly going to talk
about this value functions for safe
control where the the basic idea is that
we want to be able to take our state
space and Define a value function over
this state space that takes the desired
safety constraint and the long-term
effects of the Dynamics of your system
and composes that into a single scalar
function so if I query a particular
state it tells me by the level of that
the measure of safety so if it's
positive safe negative unsafe and the
gradient tells me the safe Direction so
it inform the constraints for my safe
control this is the basic idea of what I
would like to use we use these online
for something called Safety filters
where you say I want as much as possible
to follow the direction I'd like to
subject to maintaining these safety
properties with respect to this function
there are two communities that use this
a lot uh potentially I guess more but
two of the ones that I I see a lot right
now our control barrier functions and
Hamilton jacobe reachability analysis
I'm from this background which I'll I'll
get into in a in a minute and when I was
interviewing uh I was asked regularly
why I wasn't just using control barrier
functions and I wasn't really sure
honestly what the answer was so I made
up some some things and then when I
started my job I figured I should
actually dive into this and see what is
the relationship because both of these
are ultimately trying to find that
function that I showed on the previous
slide so my very quick
summary is if I split this up into the
initialization of how we find these
functions the construction of how we
develop these functions and then the use
of how we use these functions online
control barrier functions are very
similar to control leopo functions
they're essentially upside down leopo
functions and they come with all the
challenges of finding a control leopol
function for a nonlinear system and so
there's for initialization there's ways
to hand design these for very certain uh
types of systems where you can then find
an analytic function and it's it's very
popular to do datadriven approximations
they're trying to construct these just
from data that tells you things that are
safe and things that are not
safe but for construction in general
there's not a method for General
nonlinear Dynamic systems with control
bounds potentially disturbance bounds
there's no General constructive method
for
this uh on the reachability side of
things we typically initialize with a
signed distance function to obstacles or
failure and then we do just Brute Force
dynamic programming to that so we encode
given the Dynamics of our system what
trajectories will end up inside high
cost areas and which ones will maintain
low cost doing Brute Force dynamic
programming means that we have a very
slow but rigorous method of constructing
these functions they have General
systems input and disturbance bounds
provides the maximal safe set
Etc and then for use of this in
reachability we end up with uh an
optimal safe control where it tells me
that the change in value my change in
safety over time will always be greater
than or equal to zero this means that if
I you know start at a particular value
of safety I must be monotonically
increasing in safety so that means that
you're constantly moving upwards or at
the same level of your safety function
this is very conservative to be always
running away from obstacles forever so
instead what we use in reachability
analysis is something called least
restrictive control where we set that
threshold to zero when you're above that
threshold when you have a positive
safety value do whatever you want as you
approach the boundary of that threshold
you override it with this optimal safe
controller this is nice and that it's
least restrictive uh but you can end up
with these very choppy looking
trajectories so how we typically use
this in in reach Lilly analysis can
either be very conservative and or jerky
in practice people often do some sort of
averaging curis between the two uh but
not very
principal the control barrier side of
things uh uses this control barrier fun
uh function quadratic program which is a
QP for Contin for Control apine
Systems that's saying that minimize the
control effort such that you obey this
safety condition we now instead of V Dot
is greater than or equal to zero it's
greater than or equal to this minus
gamma V
if I plot out that minus gamma V that's
going to be this curve here and so what
we're saying is that your safety value
must stay above this curve so when
you're very safe you can decrease quite
a bit your amount of safety as you
approach the boundary of safety where
safety approaches zero you must stay
above that boundary so this is a kind of
a nice way of trading off between uh
being less restrictive when you're well
inside the safe set and more restrictive
when you're near the the boundary it's
often called like the smooth breaking
condition so you can have these nice uh
smoother trajectories that give you fast
analysis and nice
trajectories okay so that's kind of the
the very quick highle summary uh once we
looked into this we then asked well can
we smush these things together so can we
take all of the work being done on
trying to construct approximations for
control barrier functions a apply some
minimal hopefully rigorous dynamic
programming to them and then online use
this nice QP to trade off the
controllers so that's that's what I
proposed in this uh onr Yip so can
Theory and tools from Hamilton jacobe
reachability be used to construct the
best control barrier
functions next can tools for quickly
approximating control barrier functions
be used to initialize that reachability
rather than starting from that sign
distance function can we start from
something that's very close to the true
function and then finally can we update
these functions online based on changing
assumptions and
information the last one that I'm going
to mention is you know how can we reduce
conservativeness for unmodeled Dynamics
and I'll give the motivation for that
soon I'm hoping to spend most of my time
on on this and
this so first for the theore and Tool
uh to swish them together uh I'm not
going to go too far into the details but
the answer is is yes we can so in
reachability analysis the dynamic
programming that we do uh uses something
that's very similar to the bment
equation but for a continuous time and
space it looks a little bit more
intimidating but this is our our update
that we do you can think of this as the
Bellman equation the result from this in
codes this V Dot is greater than or
equal to
zero we realize that if we just just
modify this Spellman equation by just
adding that term that we want to show up
into the constraint that gamma V when we
go through the process we end up with Z
is greater than V do plus gamma V so we
embed the constraint that we want inside
of our construction of using dynamic
programming so we end up with V Dot is
greater than or equal to the minus gamma
V this allows us to obey that CBF QP
constraint with that rate gamma that
makes that curve
and so we can construct a CBF like
function that encodes control and
disturbance bounds and the maximal Decay
rate that you
want uh some a quick peek at some of the
the highlights of this work so here we
have let's say a goal and we have just
one obstacle and I'm showing the
boundary of the safe set so you're safe
when you're outside and you're unsafe
when you're inside and I'm showing a
slice at the current orientation of my
robot here if I just use my safe
controller it's going to run away from
the obstacle it does knows nothing about
the goal it's just trying to move up the
value of
safety if I do the least restrictive
control instead only activate the safe
controller when you're on the boundary
here then I end up with something that
looks like this great I reached my goal
but this is what my control trajectory
looks
like if I then instead use the CBF
QP I reach my goal and I have a much
smoother uh control signal over time
we also using this can look into um
other benefits of using Hamilton toobe
reachability like reasoning about
infinite time versus finite time safety
so here I have an example where there's
a goal and two obstacles and these are
the the unsafe sets and if I want to
guarantee infinite safety I cannot reach
this goal so if I try to reach this goal
it gets pushed away because if I reach
the skull based on my Dynamics where I
can't stop I will inevitably end up
hitting the obstacle
afterwards if say you have say a hybrid
system where once you reach a particular
goal you switch into a different state
space and so you don't care about what
happens after you reach the goal then we
can consider finite time safety so only
be safe up until you reach the goal and
then we can actually encode that into
the construction of this
function we've also flipped this around
I mentioned that control barrier
functions are upside down control leopo
functions and so with some pretty
minimal changes to the theory we're able
to uh construct control leap like
functions where for systems without
control we can conservatively estimate
the region of Attraction so here's a
region of Attraction for this system and
here is what the reachability analysis
produces for
us for systems with control we can
conservatively estimate the region now
of exponential stabilizability given a
desired Decay rate so if you want to
reach a particular goal with a very high
rate a very aggressive rate then there's
a smaller region from which you can
reach it then say if you use a a less
aggressive rate that you want to reach
the goal by and we can given the
different rates that you want we can
encode what the appropriate function
looks like and then for systems without
an equilibrium point where you're not
just stabilizing two one point uh we can
stabilize to the smallest control and
variance set around the origin so here
for a a Dubin car a car that's at a
fixed speed where it can't stop so
there's no equilibrium point its
tightest set is one in which it's doing
donuts around the origin and we can show
we can recover that you get this set and
you can stabilize down to that
donut so we just presented this in um
ACC uh and that was my very quick high
level introduction to the background
here so now we we figured out this step
and now we've started expanding into now
can we use tools from control barrier
function community in order to
efficiently initialize
this and this was led largely by my
student um sander uh who's coming to me
from a his masters with Marco uh so
thank you
Marco uh the motivation here uh is is
something like like this paper from my
colleague Sean gal at
UCSD where there's a lot of interest
developing these datadriven control
barrier functions so you gather a bunch
of trajectories um information on what's
safe and unsafe and you try to fit using
a neural network the that function that
encodes positive is safe negative is
unsafe and the gradient points you in
the direction of
safety uh this is great because it's
much more scalable than doing Brute
Force dynamic programming but you end up
with regions that do not satisfy all
these constraints when you uh use those
regions as counter examples then and
continue training then you refit your
function and test again and eventually
you may get to a point where each time
you refit your function you may uh
recover safety for those initial parts
that were unsafe but introduce new
regions that are now unsafe because of
each time that you fit it you get
something slightly different So
eventually you may get to the point
where you have something like this in
this paper all of the green trajectories
stay safe and all the orange
trajectories highlight the regions where
uh the barrier was leaky at the boundary
of the safe
set people from formal methods like my
colleague Shan gal can identify the
regions where they can formally
guarantee this and the regions where
they cannot and so can we use that
information to seed our reachability
analysis that painful dynamic
programming
method so enter my student sander here
he shows an example where he's using uh
one of these datadriven control barrier
functions as a as a safety filter
and he for example if you're trying to
reach this goal this particular function
is too aggressive in its safety so it
keeps you from being able to reach the
goal if you want to reach this
particular goal you actually end up
violating safety here so that function
was invalid the safety
filter if we use that as our
initialization for Hamilton jacobe
reachability we find that if we start
with um a a set that's too conservative
a function that describes
safe region that's too conservative each
iteration will maintain or improve the
conservativeness if we start with
something that's unsafe each iteration
of reachability will provide something
that is
safer so when he plugged in that uh that
that data driven uh control barrier
function and we did this analysis and we
continued to operate uh the dynamic
programming until convergence we ended
up with a safety filter that did this
for
example managed to maintain safety and
also increase performance uh compared to
the original uh
approximation so he presented this at
iros last year the initialization can
come from for example an analytic CBF
for a different problem formulation so
for example one that has no input
balance or slightly different Dynamics
or a constraint set it can come from an
invalid control barrier function that's
paired with a backup control policy this
is something that's popular in the cvf
field where if you have a function that
you know is wrong uh if you have some uh
backup policy like break early because
you know that the function is wrong in
these regions then you can kind of slap
that backup policy onto an addition to
your uh safety filter we can actually
now embed that policy into the
construction of the function itself and
it can also come from data driven
control barrier functions
this is nice the con convergence is much
faster than with standard Hamilton
jacobe reachability because we're
starting with something closer to the
true solution but each iteration is
still over a global grid of the state
space so in this particular work we are
still updating everywhere at every
instant of time and so it still was a
very tedious
process so now we're asking well again
Shawn was able to show you know in these
regions everything's fine and in these
regions I don't really care that much
it's not on the boundary of safety the
important regions are really around
these areas that he's identified being
leaky so our current work is on taking
one of these approximations along with
that information of what cannot be
certified to be guaranteed to be safe in
this example here is our function and
here is the 2D
slice uh at zero where you go from safe
to unsafe
and we're highlighting the points that
Sean students cannot guarantee uh obeys
the CBF uh
constraint we then use reachability
analysis in this region
locally and reason about what regions of
the space need to be active
currently and need to be
updated and we adjust the function and
the corresponding zero level set
accordingly
doing this we can
either find the barrier function
associated with the trained neural
control policy so if you trained a
control policy you don't want to modify
it and you just want to know what is the
region in which this control policy is
safe we can identify that or if you're
willing to let us mess with your control
policy we can then tweak it at this
boundary and say really you should over
IDE your policy and use this in this
region and you can maintain safety
better so we can update the control
policy along the boundary to find the
control barrier we call it value
function with the largest safe subset of
the initial safe set
approximation here's a the data a slice
of the data driven control barrier
function the safe set and green again
are the trajectories that maintain
safety and red are the ones that did not
here's what happens after we patched it
notice that we do have still a few
trajectories that that end up leaving we
believe this is has to do with this
density of the grids that we're sampling
and so we have to do some sort of
adaptive sampling method in order to
reduce uh these trajectories that
leave in terms of rolling out these
trajectories and looking at what's safe
and unsafe if we just use the neural
nominal policy that's used to train that
barrier function so we use the same
control policy that's used to make the
barrier function then both both are
fairly safe but still our patched one is
is safer if we use a different uh
control policy just lqr if you're just
trying to get to a goal using lqr and
you're using this as a true safety
filter then the neural cvf is much much
worse it's really just directly paired
with its particular control
policy our patch CBF is much
better this local patching is
approximately two orders of magnitude
faster than the original refined CBF
work um where we updated the entire grid
I say approximately because it really
depends on how good that initialization
is if it's really good and we have to
just tweak it slightly then that's great
in practice finding these data driven
CVS is quite hard and there's many many
regions that end up being questionable
that we have to deal
with so that's what we're exploring
now and then the next plan is can we
update these online based on changing
assumptions and information this is now
the next step for sander I've pointed
him towards doing experiments we're just
now starting to he has you know one
master student over the summer started
getting our Ross platform up and running
with our motion capture to start some
initial stuff we're now expanding into
using more Vehicles aerial Vehicles
Etc we also starting collaborations with
uh Nikolai atanasov and Jorge Cortez
because all of my work up until now is
assumed perfect State information so
assume that I can instantaneously get
exactly the information about the state
of my system and the state of the
obstacles in the world uh fortunately I
sit right next to professors that do not
do that and so we're going to
incorporate with their work un control
barrier functions that are robust to
measurement errors and the perception
based
navigation and then uh Sean and I are
interested in uh applying this to
henrik's robots so Henrik is the
director of our robotics Institute and
he has this Fleet of both ground robots
aerial robots but also um golf carts
autonomous golf carts that he wants to
drive around campus and not hit students
with and he said that if we get this
working then we can we can try playing
around with not hitting students
hopefully uh and so we're very excited
about moving into this
direction the problem is when you're
dealing with people now uh you have to
deal with either how how do you model
these people right uh in control we
typically assume worst case analys is
you know so assume that all humans might
be trying to run at you and throw
themselves in front of you at all times
on the learning side of things uh we
typically just do a bunch of training
and then hope that the people online in
in the real world behave the same way as
the people in the training and so how do
we deal with modeling humans have
question if you hit a student do you
have to pay their tuition that's a good
question I have no idea how Henrik gets
away with this in terms of the IRB and
all of that so that's a lot oh oh that's
my screen here that's a lot of um why I
am eager to just hop on board and let
him handle yes this
stuff anyway uh okay so this is what I
kind of mean about I'm coming from the
control side so I'm used to doing this
worst case modeling and I really don't
want to deal with that conservativeness
because you then you end up with the
freezing the robot situation where it's
afraid of every single person on campus
and doesn't move at
all
so yeah this is the motivation you have
a robot you want it to be able to get
through to other people one thing that
we do with in controls using these
safety functions is that we consider
pairwise collision avoidance so we just
slap down one of these functions on each
human that just says okay what are the
safe actions that will avoid entering
this unsafe set with respect to this one
this one this one you consider them
completely independently and then you
say I want to minimize the difference
between my desired control subject to
obeying the safe actions with respect to
each
person um note you can also take the
pointwise Min to make one CBF though you
may have some differentiability
issues uh there's a problem though with
doing that so analytical or dynamic
programming based control barrier
functions for pairwise collision
avoidance tend to assume that the
actions of other agents are all equally
likely this is the worst case analysis
that I mentioned so you know if I'm
assuming that any human might go
anywhere at once then I have this huge
unsafe set and the robot has to take
very very conservative
Behavior data diven control barrier
functions the stuff that Sean's dealing
with are very sensitive to the training
environment and may not be
representative in other environments so
as an extreme illustration let's say you
trained in an environment with just one
person and so you ended up with a safe
set that pretty much said just don't go
in front of the person they tend to walk
in straight
lines now if you were to test on a
environment with two people now you
assume that these people are completely
independent and therefore can walk
through each other and so the unsafe
sets will look something like this and
you say great they will walk through
each other and I can take this
trajectory right nearby them and clearly
we do did not capture some of the
interaction effects that happen between
humans by training on just one again
extreme example but to
illustrate so the core issue here is
that I want to maintain these
independent control barrier functions
for scaling reasons being able to just
see a human slap down a function see a
human slap down a function is great
because I don't have to think about
their joint Dynamics and reason about
the joint State
space but I also want to encode
interaction effects which kind of Seems
like by definition you have to reason
about joint things so are these two
desires completely at odds I thought yes
Sean said no and he uh propos this idea
so let's imagine that you're this robot
in this dense environment you know that
it's a dense environment but you're only
focusing on one person and you see that
they're moving and you reason you know
can I safely move forward given how
they're moving well yes probably they're
going to keep moving straight If instead
you see that this person suddenly makes
a turn knowing that you're in a dense
crowd you could probably infer that
they're making this turn because there
is some interaction effect that's
happening with another human and
therefore taking that path is not safe
instead of explicitly doing all this
reasoning if we trained in an
environment with multiple
people uh then we could encode these
interaction effects implicitly just by
crashing when you crash into the second
person and you mark that as unsafe you
eventually learn that when this person
moves this way you probably shouldn't
move
straight so the idea is train and
environment of multiple agents but only
measure the current and a little bit of
history of One
agent keep track of what age actions
lead to Collision versus safety with
anybody and use this to train a pairwise
collision control barrier
function we call this idea a sequential
neural
CBF where the training procedure now is
we're going to use trajectory samples to
get a rough landscape of the control
barrier function
and then we're going to resample around
the boundary of the safe set to refine
it and I'll show you what I mean by that
in a
second so the training procedure is we
have a loss function that encodes that
first the value of safe State should be
positive so this penalizes if the value
of certain states that are safe is
negative we're here this is the agent
State this is the human State sequence
and this gives us an error margin
so I sum this up over all of the states
that are in the safe set and ensure that
if any of them are marked as negative
that that's uh encod in the loss
function vice versa the value of unsafe
States should be negative so now we have
that we're summing over the unsafe set
and we took out the negative sign here
and then finally the gradient should
obey that CBF QP condition with that
gamma term where as we approach the
boundary of safety we have to uh act
more safely so just those three terms in
the loss function we take the agent
State and the agent obstacle relative
States throw that through an MLP and
lstm and end up with this barrier
function conditioned on the relative
State and that
history this is what it looks like these
are the two different um steps this is
the initial stage and this is the
refining stage here in red is the
average path length to the goal and in
blue is the Collision rate over training
time
for the training and testing setup in
simulation and in person for the
simulation environments the training is
performed with six human pedestrians
using Orca for the
policy and then for experiments the
training is performed with two human
pedestrians using grad
students for evaluation we randomly
initialize the robot human and goal
configurations in denser environments
and if at any point in the trajectory
the robot I a collides with a human or
cannot find a safe control action then
we consider that full trajectory of
failure so if there's any feasibility
issues we consider that a
failure how we compose this online is
the same way as we said before where
every time I see a human I just slap
down one of these barrier functions and
then I say minimize the difference
between my my desired uh control and the
control that's required to uh satisfy
all the safety constraints so I'm still
treating these completely independently
in terms of how I'm reasoning online
so this is these are the um level sets
of these functions that were slapped
down by the grad
student uh but where the hope is that in
the shape of the function I am
implicitly capturing these interaction
effects these are some baselines that we
compared to first uh sampling based
potential field methods so here we're
using potential fields which are like
control barrier functions without
Dynamics I have repulsive fields around
each obstacle and attractive fields
around the goal based on ukian distance
in each step we sample actions and
evaluate the predicted next states of
those actions we have a gradient based
version of that where the control is
based on the gradients of the potential
field we compare to a blackbox
multi-agent control barrier function so
this is just using our normal data
driven control barrier
function uh here we're using the max
pooling layer in order to deal with uh
extra uh people in the
environment We compare also to a
sampling based model predictive control
where we learn a d neural Dynamics model
and then unroll it online to generate a
tree of future States and select the
action that leads to the best predicted
outcome and then we also compare it to
PPO and
dqn first let's look at just these three
so here's using a robot that's a double
integrator a bicycle and a dubin's car
uh in blue is our method in orange and
green and red are these appropriate
methods and you see that our our method
scales even though we trained in just
six people as we go up to 600 people in
the same environment our method tends to
avoid Collision much better than these
other
methods we can keep the Collision rate
under 10% when scaling to 60 times dener
environments and the Collision only
reaches 15% in a bicycle model case with
a 100 time denser environment than the
training I note that the Gap in safety
is more significant when the robot has
more complicated Dynamics such as the
non-holonomic Dubin car we're actually
embedding the Dynam dynamics of the
robot into the construction of this
function is
important here's kind of an example of
of where this works well here we have a
narrow Corridor situation where two
humans are passing by each other if
you're using potential field methods
then just following the gradient
directly ends up causing the robot to
turn and actually
Collide whereas here looking at the
level sets of the control barrier
function you see that the robot is able
to navigate through the space by looking
at the history of the agents so here's
with the bicycle and with the
car uh note that the CBF that encodes
the bicycle Dynamics has a wider gap
between level sets AK a steeper gradient
reflecting the need to initiate
collision avoidance much farther away
from the
obstacles because of the Dynamics of the
system okay let's compare to
NPC so standard NPC requires the use of
analytic Dynamics so both the ego robot
and the humans and so we can't just
throw NPC into this without modifying it
somewhat so instead that's why we find
that neural Dynamics and then we we roll
it out we sample actions and forward
predict the future States 10 or 100 uh
and then select actions based on the
potential field values of those
predicted States and we also consider
the case where the sampling based model
predictive control has access to the
true dynamics of the human so we tell it
exactly what the humans are going to do
and allow it to do MPC this is in order
to get kind of like a a baseline an
Oracle in a way because you can imagine
if there's 600 people in a space perhaps
there does not exist a safe path to your
goal so that one where we give the NBC
access to what the humans really are
doing this is what the curve looks like
there here's for the other sampling
based methods and then here's ours we
think that ours work better here because
it does not require multi-step unrolling
and it avoids the accumulation of model
prediction errors that are inherent in
the Learned model models of
Dynamics okay and then finally there's
so many baselines that we compare to
because it kept getting rejected from
machine learning conferences so we just
kept adding more baselines so let's do
now Po and
dqn so here again we train an
environment with six tested on 600 uh
and we actually in each of these cases
we use the action produced by po or dqn
as the nominal action that we want to
use in rqp so we say try to follow this
action and just override it if you need
safety and you know we're able to deal
with denser environments because we made
our method better at scaling uh than
just uh standard uh
training and then we have a little
initial Hardware demo we now moved into
our fancy new building uh and so I have
a lot more room to play around with and
all of henrik's toys but for the initial
one in this small temporary lab space we
have the training with two people ignore
the person carrying the battery that was
just uh the battery
holder and the the robot is trying to
get you know along this path is is what
its desired reference is and then we
test this in environment more people
note again because it's a small
environment the people have to kind of
move awkwardly around each other so we
really want to do this differently and
now that we have more room but so the
the we're trying to follow again the
same path and you see that often like
here the robot has to deviate quite a
bit from that path in order to main
safety with respect to the people um
here the people were told to look up and
not look down at the robot at all and
just interact with each other um this is
an assumption that we're making in
general in order to help with data
augmentation that humans do not react to
the robot which is a silly assumption
that we're trying to now
tackle um okay so in summary we exploit
the important observation that the
spatial interaction patterns of multiple
obstacles can be decomposed and
predicted through sequential modeling of
individual obstacles so we can take a
spatial interaction and instead encode
that as temporal
information we design these models that
incorporate sequential modeling of
individual obstacles so they can be
composed in environments with an
arbitrary number of obstacles online
next we want to do our larger scale
experimental validation and some
analysis of the probabilistic safety
properties of the methods under certain
assumptions on the environments um we
just presented this at IRS and actually
then won the robocup best paper award so
I guess submit keep getting your things
rejected from machine learning things
build up all your baselines and then
submit to robotics seems like a pretty
good strategy I don't know but I it it
turned into a pretty good paper I think
oh and consider other information that
we can encode into the control barrier
function okay so that's the kind of
pitch that I told on onr that's the
things that we had been working on I
went to again again highlight my PhD
students my undergraduate and master
students and all my collaborators for
this particular project the green thrust
was done uh by uh students Jason and
Dong gun uh and their advisers koshel
and Claire at
Berkeley with me and then my student
Jung did the extension to control the
apov functions along with my ta who is a
student of Tom buy for the second one
quickly approximating cbfs and use that
forish ation my students sander and Alex
who's now at brain Corp worked on that
along with sha gal and his students
updating these online based on changing
assumptions and information sander is
now guiding a team of undergraduate and
master students for doing experiments
now that we've moved into our space and
for reducing the conservativeness for
unmodeled Dynamics that's work with Shan
and his
students and that with that I am done
and happy to talk now about questions
and comments and concerns if we don't
get to all of these things for you uh my
email is very easy to remember it's s
Herbert or Sherbert at ucsd.edu and with
that I am done thank
[Applause]
you for questions so I hope we'll get
some all what are like the steps you
have to take and are there any unique
steps you have to take to discretize the
CBF hjr uh sort of formulation that you
you showed for the patching thing no no
like way earlier on I think it was in
the green section or the blue section
you showed the formulation where you
included the CBF requirement with the
hjr formulation but that's done in
continuous time when you implement it
yes when you implement it you do it on a
discretized state space and all this
Hamilton jacobe reachability stuff is
done ultimately on a discre state space
using dynamic programming because we
have digital computers and so yes
there's a lot both in space and time you
have to sample finely enough and there's
work on what finely enough means in fact
if you really want to bother
someone is somewhere and you should
track him
down it's really um more of an
observation I I thought it was
interesting that you were starting to
work with with real robots because of
course they do have uncertain sensing
there is noise and so on and um you
started to say a little bit how how
you're dealing with that and I even
noticed in the video that you showed at
the end of people walking around you say
well two people are walking towards each
other they're going to see each other
but even when there isn't anybody coming
towards you I saw people walking and
then just sort of randomly making SHP
turns to the left or right yeah I don't
know yeah absolutely so some of the work
that I did in my PhD with um with Claire
and with Ana Dron was on uh can you get
away with using really dumb models of
humans and when they obey your dumb
models then you have very tight
confidence around them and when they act
differently whatever that means uh then
you degrade your confidence and end up
in in the in the extreme considering the
worst case example so how do you switch
between uh levels of confidence here I
think we'd be curious to incorporate
something like that in in here but
there's this trade-off between yeah how
much reasoning do you want to do online
versus offline how are you reasoning
about uncertainty yeah all of that we're
very interested in the state estimation
stuff we're very interested in there's
uh a project with um another TA of mine
who now comes to my group meetings who
uh is interested in how do you reason
about what is the state that is best to
believe you are in uh in order to be
robust rather than the state that you
most likely to be in uh so so we're
exploring some some things like that
which has been fun and and good for me
when I've been very much protected in
this world of just assuming perfect
information and I pushing out of
it so On a related note could you share
a bit more about how you are considering
uh the human response to the robot
moving around them yes thank you so um
as i' it's been forced upon me because
one of my students um nille here he's uh
co-advised by Mike Yip at UCSD who is in
Surgical Robotics and he wants to do
safe surgical robotics which is a crazy
hard thing for him to want to do uh but
so we're starting off with the the
rubble thing that I showed you before
the Pringle scans where we say okay
let's not tug on people's tissue but
let's start with some Pringle scans you
want to try to push them around in order
to get to the goal without knocking
things over where eventually we're
hoping to move that towards how do you
tug and move around tissue in such a way
that you maintain safety while getting
towards your goal with the da Vinci
robot anyway
he wants to try uh porting this over
onto that situation where now the humans
are Pringle scans uh and we were very
excited about that and then we realized
you know Pringles cans do not move
independently like they literally will
only respond based on actions that you
take as the robot so we actually have to
deal with this fact that the humans and
robots are humans and robots are
interacting and so it in terms of the
training itself it doesn't break too
much the process C of what we do at a
high level but it does change how we
have to uh gather data so before we
would take you know some some samples of
robots and human moving across the lab
and then postprocessing we would ask
okay what if the robot was here or here
or here would it have remained safe and
by assuming that the humans ignore the
robot we can just use the same recording
of the human trajectories and be able to
refine our safe set using that now we
have to actually gather enough data with
actually knocking around Pringles cans
in order to do that so we're exploring a
few different methods for how to deal
with that uh and that is very much still
in the active exploration side of things
so if people have ideas i' I'd love to
hear
them
questions okay perfect well again if you
have any follow-up thoughts comments
questions please feel free to reach out
to me um and I'm also here for the rest
of the day all right thanks so
[Applause]
much